[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lad and what a lad i have for
you today not only is today's guest one
of the most exciting backs in the
country with his footwork speed and
strength of doom he is also one of the
nicest guys you'll meet and that was
confirmed after is happy enough to go
around to keith's house for a roast
haggis but i'm stoked to have this lead
on he is one of the greats it is jonah
welcome mate
thank you thank you phil i feel so
welcome to be here it's almost my
podcast
mate i've been trying to get you on for
a while i've been looking forward to
sitting down and having a yarn with you
but made us awesome seeing you back out
there i know you had a bit of an injury
a decent injury last year but awesome to
see you back up on the field and
uh from the from your form so far this
season looks like you're straight back
to the form that you left off with
yeah 100 i'm glad to be back i missed it
a lot uh oh olden said ninja i think i
had a sabbatical really
actually loved it i actually loved my
sabbatical my wee sabbatical got up to
some good old uh fun
picked up some new hobbies but um yeah
nah glad to be back into it and how is
your body feeling how's your knee
feeling
yeah my knees feeling unreal um way more
confidence in it um in the last probably
like two two to three months um leading
up to
the mitre 10 um sorry the bunnings cup
so yeah nah
i've enjoyed my rehab and
i guess
knowing more about my body than
you actually think you do
yeah
and you i mean you went off in the game
against tasman in the weekend but that
was that just a little scare i mean it
sort of saved us you were carving us up
in that first 20 minutes
yeah no i was quite
now i was uh actually i'm out for eight
weeks now which is uh [ __ ] uh
yeah so i uh ruptured something in my
ankle so i just had my skin an mri
yesterday
um ruptured something in my ankle but um
lucky enough that i don't
need surgery so i was kind of hoping
that i wouldn't need surgery cause then
it'll push me up to three to four months
but uh yeah not eight weeks so i could
be able i shouldn't be able to play the
last two rounds of the bunnings cup so
[ __ ] i think i came out too hot really
came out too hot for the body
made another eight week sabbatical you
love it yeah
that's why i said what you must be
enjoying your sabbaticals i was aha
i'm telling you it chooses me i don't
choose it
but how was the whole rehab process
you obviously enjoyed your time off the
field but what was how did you find that
whole process
um i found i found it quite um
interesting
just because like i've played footy for
probably since out of school all the way
through so i didn't have no major injury
um so this was probably the first major
one that i've ever had so um to sit back
and especially on a super rugby team and
watch
um
from the sidelines and have that point
of view um was kind of
uh it was good but then bad just because
our team uh just because the landers
weren't doing as great as uh i would
like them to
as i'd like them to be
um so yeah i felt left out but then also
like it was kind of good that
i had a few niggles as well so refreshed
my whole body really to to be back so
that's probably why i
came out firing in that in that
tasmanian game and then boom
and go back to another sabbatical
and you obviously got plenty of arm work
um in in your off season and your weak
sabbatical because your arms are looking
massive
oh do you reckon
looking pretty normal i reckon it's
almost it's almost the fishing i've been
doing that's i've been catching so many
blue cod
tears to get put put a toll on your arms
i reckon
oh classic but one thing i do want to
mention before we do get into um your
life and your whole journey is um the
prank obviously
um it was a prank that i was pretty
nervous about because i hadn't met you
before um
asking you to come around to kathy's
house for a roast haggis and a cuddle
uh you know i had the heart pumping but
maybe i was just blown away by what
allowed you were to accept the invite
and get around keen to head around for
dinner what do you remember about it
oh so it was like you called me and i
was driving i was driving to the airport
i don't know who i was picking up but
somehow i was just driving to the
airport and i was just like
how am i gonna like tell this person
like like do i tell this person do i
tell keithy like oh just message me and
then i'll just tell him how to know i
ain't coming like
but like in person like over the phone i
was like oh no like i'll be keen to come
over and then what you said oh then we
can cuddles are on
i was like no keith you must want more
and then um there was something that
happened that kind of like oh then he
said he said he said messages me the
next the next day or something and it's
like how was your phone call and i was
like
i knew it was a stitch up like i knew it
was a stitcher
no it was cold though
i thought you might have picked up on at
the back end of that combo when i did
mention hisa and um the cuddle but mate
was it a couple of days later then um he
submisses you that you realize that it
wasn't yeah right
no because like he said he's pretty
marginal to himself really like he gives
a lot of hugs away to some some people
so like i just thought it'd be normal
for he said to be giving cuddles and
haggis is there right so well this would
be normal for jesus i was like you must
be one of his mates
and then he misses me afterwards and i
thought this was a prank but this is
definitely a prank
oh one of the greats i do love that one
i listened back to it last night and had
a good old laugh but
like i mentioned i do want to hear a
little bit more about your life what
what life was like as a young fella for
you where'd you grow up
i grew up in wanganui
the land of the big white long brown
river
it knows that's an amazing town actually
oh i actually ran it now
yeah it depends how you see it but no it
was a great town um
small
so now it's good
oh just growing up just watching like
jericho and uh
probably i just wanted to become one of
them especially in the super rugby scene
um and then i spent like
i was at uh london city college for like
year 9 10 11 and 12 and then
he got me into uh fielding x so that
turned on my last year i got over to
fielding ag
and then i kind of like really got into
my footy deals like real serious over
there so
um that's where it kind of took off for
me
were you always good as a young kid
coming through
nah nah nah i was i was i was average i
was average surprisingly i was number i
was uh i was a 10 back in the day
that doesn't surprise me at all
yeah people would like me like dc
people used to call me dc like the
chocolate dc
were you goal-kicking
oh i did i did kind of like once my legs
got a bit tighter i used to just push it
over as you know people do you just push
it over once once it gets to the silo
you start giving it to other people
but i could imagine you being quite
talented at a few different things was
it was it always rugby for you or did
you have a few other
options or sports that you did
now i um in the summer i used to play
cricket
and yeah back in back in uh back in
organized to play cricket just because
it was like a there's nothing to do in
the summer really so i just played
cricket and the cricket team were like
battling for numbers so i just used to
just go
be a fielder used to um
he just used to oh i want to say bowl
because all the boys will rip me in but
uh yeah i was probably one of the i was
probably the top five batsman um you
know pretty good to be honest i i don't
want to bring my own tires out but holy
heck i could smash a six
were you a big header is that is that
was that sort of your game plan my most
weeks
yeah just come out firing that's what
the coach used to tell me
i just want you to go out there jonah
and just get as much runs as you can i
don't care if you get out that's how you
say no more
it's a good good mindset i like that oh
yeah hundred percent hundred percent and
then there's some touch i could imagine
you being a pretty sharp touch player
nah i've never played touch a like
surprisingly i've never ever played
corporate like touch not like yeah new
zealand type touch so i've never ever
played it
basketball yeah
yeah some people call me like ray allen
and stuff when i'm on the court like
just because i always hit him i'm a
green light type person on the corner
but um you know it's not it's not
something that i would go down but yeah
basketball
what about that
all these things all these things that
are springing to mind because like you
look like a talented guy
now more i love volleyball lately
volleyball's probably like one of the
yeah volleyball uh i used to i love
playing table tennis um
just do i enjoy oh april pool oh that's
probably one of the like my main hobby
is april paul i
[Music]
yes especially after a you know nice wee
joke
it gets the heart pumping
so then what how did you go from um
fielding to professional footy what was
the pathway for you
fielding i uh i made uh
the barbarians the new zealand
barbarians team um
and then from there i kind of got
scattered to come down to otago um but
like the thing is i wanted to come down
to otago this is a story for you
so uh
i i catch up with my agent comes over to
uh oh the white locks are real big a so
at a fielding egg so they say oh i've
got this um i've got this agent that i
want you guys to meet and these three of
us is me volimony and one of these uh
one of the other boys his name's tom
so oh um
he can he can find out where you guys
want to go and he could be your agent
which you guys want and
so as you know me and my parents fills
his parents and tom's parents we all
went to this uh
meeting over at the white lox house and
our agent or old warren he goes oh
so where do you want to go jonah and i
was like oh
what am i going down to dunedin
and then he was oh yeah what would you
want to do
mechanics course
oh me me and me so then like on the
drive home like short story short uh
long story short i'm gonna drive home my
mom's like oh do you know with the
needle nuts and i'm like oh yeah but
it's in the south island like easy
so in my head i didn't tell my mum that
i thought christchurch was dunedin so
like above and i don't know dunedin was
way below so then anyway um warren
susses out this um
this flight that's like i come down to
dunedin for a couple of days
and then like check out the facilities
and go to the politics etc and then fly
back up
on the way on the way to the airport
like two weeks later on the way to the
airport my mom was like you should
really like google where the needle is
and i was like oh yeah okay whatever you
want what yeah okay so the needle i
struggle with the needle there's and i
just see that it's at the bottom of
christchurch and my heart just slices it
just sinks to the bottom and i'm like oh
and then i quickly click on the images
and i just all i see is snow like just
snow like snow there's snow there and
i'm like
mom i don't i don't think i can live
there and like by this time it's like
too late you know i've already like
signed these things and i've got to make
this work but
yeah i kind of just wanted to go down so
i can be away from them and then try to
be independent but kind of didn't work
out well because i just came straight to
this nice family um this nice club
family and oh my gosh the lady there
sandy she was amazing she'd like
should cook us like maybe like a
four course meal like every like every
dinner she was so good like i probably
gained about four kgs at the house but
you know it was just amazing that i
opted to come down here and now it's
home for me which i i i rate um
which is good but you were hoping to go
to christchurch was it nah so i thought
that
christchurch yeah i just thought that
dunedin and christchurch it was just
going to be warm up like one of them's
just going to be just closer to the
like nelson lovely place so oh you know
so it's pretty yeah so it's going to be
up here like nearly
but nah it's the opposite it's near
antarctica more than nelson
that's all chatted about
oh but you obviously love it down there
now so then how did you um how did you
go from
you missed out on the new zealand
schools but you made new zealand 20. so
um how did you manage to do that
yeah
yeah that was funny because i we did
this uh that provincial um under 19's
tournament in tupelo and i had the
probably the most shockingest tournament
i've ever had in my entire life and
anyway i um i didn't get picked for the
for the camps and um
there was a like i think there was like
three camps so there was a first camp
second camp and the third camp i think
that was the last camp that they
they were going to name the under 20
side and one of the boys got injured and
then they're like oh could you just
could you just go up and just uh jump in
one of the trials team so i was like oh
yes we all just
got up and trolling
and we played um we played the chiefs
and at that time it was like simply
severe reese was playing and i was like
and i kind of knew him from school so
like
and i was just like this guy's beast you
know he was a sacrifice back then but
they pushed him to the wing just to play
us
holy and he was just trying to run over
me the whole time and i was just tying
his shoelaces for moses
so then like from there
i was lucky enough like funny enough
like i made the i made that team to go
over to aussie with no injuries and they
made i'm not too sure what they did but
they yes i i made that team to aussie
which was quite cool um
and then i think they're going to cut
that team down
from their aussie team to go to the
world cup they're going to cut it down i
think they'll supposed to cut like two
backs uh two outside backs but lucky
enough they took the two outside backs
which was pretty cool so then i was uh
pretty blessed to go to georgia for the
um
the world cup
and that was quite cool because i just
went for another sabbatical really went
over there for holiday they didn't play
one game oh actually i did play one game
but
no we had a stack with a stacked outside
back so um yeah now i enjoyed i enjoyed
the the timing within the experience so
who was ahead of you
uh there was caleb clark it was teema
um
i think braden in all was covering deals
with jordan there was josh mackay
yes so there was like a lot of boys that
could yeah it was not it was not bad uh
outside back then so yeah now it was
great to be a part of and then like
seeing everyone now um in the super and
then all black so
it's quite cool to
to see yeah and then post that for you
you went into the new zealand sevens
camp eh
yeah yeah yeah so i went to the junior
series camp that was probably
just because i didn't have any any super
or anything so i just went to do some
sevens and i quite actually write today
like just traveling the world um
[Music]
seeing different parts of the world uh
especially it's it's different it's not
as
not as what people think it is you know
it's actually like such a hard game and
like you yeah it's probably the one
thing that gets me is like player so
like once you finish a game you're like
tied but like you share changing groups
so like you share change your own so
normal change room you share with like
three teams so
you could be like with fiji and kenya
you know so you're like listening to
three different musics right and you're
listening to allen music like pumping
and then you're hearing songs and you're
hearing the kenyan songs and you're like
yo this is actually unreal but it's
probably the hardest one is like you
kind of they have to
recover somehow real quick
in order to play again so that's
probably one thing i uh
took as something important is like
recovery especially when when it comes
to like uh
high performance type sport as uh you're
recovering and how do you find the
environment the new zealand sevens
environment
oh it was great it was great just
because i was in that modded tin i was
in that mitre 10 um environment and you
know how like you're like in a in a
group of what 30 plus
or 15 players and you're like you have
all your different groups
but like in the seventh squad there's
only like 12 views on tour so it's just
always a group of users always going
with each other which is like it's yeah
great bonding like unreal environment
especially like because
coaching and the management and the
players are real close together so
i loved it i loved it sounds like you
had a good time because
um not often i get so many questions
from one team coming from instagram but
the sevens boys they came in and
truckloads so i do want to go for the
mid question
podcast questions here um with some of
the some of the ones that came in so i
haven't done this before but i think
this is probably the best way to get
through
some of these questions because you did
get plenty in but first one any good
promos in vancouver this one obviously
came from reagan where the lair
freaking where the lad of lads yeah no
surprisingly i did this it was a real
nice one with by trail trail joes and um
it was like it was it was actually put
well i think it was a stitch up really
like i think it actually was a stitcher
and it was like with these uh like
netflix um
like netflix actors it was quite yeah it
was quite um
yeah weird in a way because we didn't
know what we were doing but just yeah
video like it was just like over video
but like there was no like script or no
it was very weird like and then it was
just for themselves it wasn't anything
to do with
i think the new zealand team it was just
like
vancouver
stevens tying into netflix or something
like that what were those netflix
actors yeah it was real but hey it was
great hey it was it was unreal like we
got free feed
um the first time tasting um wagyu beef
so i was like
i used to watch it on youtube so i was
quite happy with it like hey i took
something out of it and was the wagyu
beef and now you can't get anywhere else
so what was it like you were just
yawning to actors and it was being
filmed and never got played in yeah
oh i think it got played over there
because do you know how the netflix is
different oh yeah yeah
what was it like a netflix special
that's good stuff okay next one um this
is vancouver as well why is vancouver
your favorite sevens tournament sam
dixon
oh probably just the people the people
are unreal
like
for example like you know new zealand's
new zealand like the seventh team is not
like you don't just we can't just rock
into the airport and everyone's just oh
my gosh the seventh team yeah you know
but in vancouver holy they think we're
like you know the nba team were oh my
and i'm like i'll sit over there
come down calm down it's telling me that
now i just it's just great like they
they they put the they put rugby on like
this mess of peter school so um yeah
that's it's great and then
this stadium is quite um great
especially
there um what do you call those massive
like screens in the middle of like nba
uh
big
yeah
screen
call it something yeah whatever they're
called
it starts with t but yeah yeah yeah now
they have one of those so it's quiet you
know when you get a try you look up and
you say
that's how lebron james does stuff
oh you would have been in your zone
oh i was yeah and then like i don't know
i'm not too sure oh then silas is old
sass i'm not too sure if he was there
when i was in vancouver but oh my gosh
that guy's a winner too but anyway
another story well speaking of christmas
got a question from sas as well
how's choc mechanic going from jaunty
from dante himself oh it's actually
quite good it's going good actually um
what is the choc mechanic
the truck mechanic so i did a mechanics
course here uh on my first year down
here um in 2016
and i was supposed to do my
apprenticeship the next two years and i
kind of like oh no i put on pause like
rugby's gonna i think rugby's gonna take
off here i can't be doing both you know
but you know
oh so i did this mechanics course and
everyone thinks it's like i'm like i'm
lying but honestly i could fix cars
i don't know about fixing like people's
cars but i'll probably fix my own car
um so so anyway i can't i'm not too sure
if i should tell you the story but um
this might get this might come out to my
my work my um the work experience guys
that i used to work for you know in cook
store um i did work experience on a
friday and
um i was unreal i was unreal like cars
come in cars went out cars come and cars
went out probably like 30 minutes i
probably went through how many services
these were not normal services these are
transmission services and engine
services filters changed washed browsing
everything hands grease everywhere
anyway so i was um i was you know doing
my thing on a friday overall steel cat
boots boom bang
cold
i was just pumping through them and then
uh this one day it was like near
lunchtime and then the the boss and his
uh his colleague were like oh
jenna can you do quickly do this this
car and it just needs to get out before
lunch and then i was like oh okay yeah
sweet and then they left for lunch so
i'm like sweet so i like get under the
card and do everything
change the filter
i put the car back down on the hoist and
i'm like filling it with a gun
filling it with the gun and like you
gotta kind of put like four leaders into
it and i'm like filling it and i'm
sitting on the thing like
two three four on the gun it's like just
on a digital screen so three four and
i'm like oh oh that might be it so i
like stopped again but and then i start
to move and i can hear a puddle like i'm
but this is inside a garage i'm like why
is there a puddle so like look under the
car and i forgot to put the bung
we've got to put the bug so there's four
leaders is just going straight in the
car come back out and hit the floor and
i'm like oh my my heart is racing so i
put this horse back up put the bunk back
in and i'm like oh these guys are going
to be here soon so i'll go get these
regular cut open these rags and i'm just
chucking on the ground and i'm just
mopping this ground like i've got to get
rid of this evidence and then i reset
the gun and i'm like oh
like real panicky and then like as soon
as they like start to drive into the
garage i'm like i'm like the guns in and
i'm like filling it down oh that's good
work like you're exciting to follow i
was like yeah yeah i wasn't too bad
anymore but until they stay they don't
know but if this podcast comes out
they'll probably know
that they need a they need to charge me
four liters of engine oil
you did well to cover that up
yeah i was i was in panic like i was
panicking and it was it was weird
because like it was uneven surfaces so
the oil was like dripping everywhere
like so it wasn't just in a puddle even
yeah
whatever mechanically jeez you got
through some of some work in that
morning shift by the sounds of it
oh i used to get into oh
i used to get into some shift i think
they want me back then just because of
that but
maybe if i yeah maybe i'll go do
something working my eight weeks of
article that i have now
okay next one how did it feel being the
eighth strongest in blc from stubby
another lad
another lad yeah blc is big lifters club
the only only only a special
special few get to be uh named the blc
and i was probably one of the ogs i
don't know why you're saying the eighth
because i was probably the first
um
for me it was it was more like a mindset
type thing and that's what like broke me
that's what uh my point of difference is
compared to those others
um mindset mindset you know
like
mindset to lift it you know like i could
just lift all of my head doesn't mean i
can lift it with my arms you know it's
all up here it's all up here jim
oh i like that myself oh
what a lifter okay next one are you
still practicing tippy toes another one
from regs
yeah that's probably why i might
actually um unfortunately riggs i am not
because
just ruptured my ankle so i definitely
haven't been doing any um to be too
type exercises unfortunately
we're quite a big practiser of it
yeah i was a real good practicer like
i'd probably be like over time type
person
get into it and i just love the burn i
just love that bird and i'll just like
you know tell the boys like you need to
do this
but you know they thought you know they
thought it was a piss stick but i was
like mate
what what's the difference between me
and you you know
magic there was nothing really but
what is it
okay last one from one of the sevens
lads this one was from your coach ask
him about the voice activated tv at the
world cup with salisi from clarky
so uh
hey great question there clarkie so me
and sas were roommates and everyone
everyone in there um sevens who were at
the world cup and everyone so everyone
had like great roommates you know like
and i don't know why i had sex like
so i flipped around and i told you maybe
maybe this is like a maybe they're
challenging me here to be a leader maybe
they're actually like hey it can be a
leader to sass so
being the choco man i am i'll take him
under my wing
and anyway we get into our room and uh
me and seth are just chilling there and
i have the remote underneath my uh the
blanket and i'm just lying in bed i'm
like bro says there's um tv's a voice
activated hey
and he's like no they're not not here
they are
and then he was like show me then i was
like oh
tv turn on and i like push the button
underneath the blanket and the tv turns
on
and then
like this legit this goes on for like
two days
and like the thing is i was like i was
telling cess like oh it's only on my
voice
and then ah
went awful like legit two days no joke
and he was gutted because i hid the
remote so like the only way is
and he brought his playstation so the
only way he could play his playstation
shock hurry up come to the room so you
could turn the tv on and i was like oh
yeah so i started i started telling
everyone that oh no i told him there was
voice activated
anyway uh it comes to the third day and
i'm like oh here
and i grabbed something like something
random like not even a remote and i just
grabbed it and i'm like oh talk talk to
this and like hopefully your voice goes
to the tv like this is the the mic yeah
and um i think it was like like a little
thing of like the alarm clock or
something i don't know something random
and i was like oh just talk to this like
say your name and like so he's like
popping up saying his name and stuff
and i'm just cranking up when you know
it
so i
day three or day four comes along and
i'm like i'm in the i'm brushing my
teeth and all i hear is tv turn on
[Laughter]
and i'm just like giggling away and he's
like volume up to 15 and i'm just loling
in the light i'm just rolling in the
bathroom like [ __ ] this guy's got me and
i'm just saying he's like what are you
laughing at us
what's wrong he said that's not working
okay so i jumped back into bed and i
like got the remote again and i was like
doing it oh
tv 15.
anyway like someone accidentally like
told him at lunch they're like chuck's
playing tricks on you holy heck and he
felt oh
and he didn't he didn't talk to me for a
good day he was there angry
but like that was probably one of the
greatest stories i've ever told was
as the voice activation tv story right
that is so good he's classic for a prank
too old celisi oh he is
one of the greats one of the greatest
golfers i've ever seen too
style-wise but i don't know about his
game
no he's definitely definitely one in a
million oh he sure is but mate sounds
like yeah it sounded like you had a hell
of a time in that sevens camp was it did
you ever think about staying in there or
was 15 is always the dream for you yeah
15's was always the dream for me um it
kind of got a bit repetitive with the
sevens uh set up just because like
i'm not too sure like if they evolve in
a lot of things
there's only seven people on the field
like you can only do so much so um
yeah uh
i would go back to it if i um
if they had millions dollars there but
100 you probably train more than you
play to be honest um
all right it was great for the body like
great for the body and hey great setup
up and turning up and about so um yeah i
think 15s was was where i wanted to be
and um i think yeah you can go way
further in a rugby career with with
fifteens than seven so
so how did you find going into the otago
setup
eels it was uh my first year actually i
thought i chose the wrong team because i
had like the the otago outside backs
were stacked back then it was like tony
insult
jack wilson matt faddis
uh fussy fort tight so they'll like you
know they're like experienced players
and then like 2017 they just all left
just got up and left and i was like holy
so then i was like oh i'm the next
person in line so they had to pick me so
i was kind of happy with it
but um yeah
probably the thing for me is like i had
to make it work so
i came down to had to make it work and i
wasn't much of a drinker back then so i
didn't really get into uh the scarfy
life so
um real focused and playing rugby so um
yeah no i i really enjoyed it
well and how i did it um i don't think
if i did it differently i don't think i
would be where i am today because it's
kind of hard to be a scarfy and a rugby
player i must admit like
some people can but i definitely reckon
if i did it i would have went the other
way and becoming a professional drinker
probably become a professional striker
at full sidebar
that would be a tough streak at a tackle
i'm telling you now imagine that right
you'd be your first trigger to ever have
rugby boots on
were you always confident going into
that um environment playing your first
few games for otago because you seem
like a confident guy did you always feel
have that confidence on the field
nah definitely not i was probably i was
probably real shy
i think as the years uh
got on um with playing rugby um getting
older i think i started to get uh way
more confidence
in myself and like what how powerful you
can be especially if like fans and kids
look up to you
like they don't want to see someone
that's shy and
or not not try but um not confident in
what like you believe in so um there's
probably one thing i've taken away is
like the confident you are the the more
a fan or kid would want to be like you
yeah kind of flip it like that if
if yeah if i had a idol back in the day
what would i want them to be like and
how would i want them to act if i was in
the same room as them so
so were you always confident as a kid
like we're always one of the guys who
are comfortable to get up in front of
the class and do a song or dance or
stuff but or you sort of taught yourself
to be this confident
now probably taught myself how to be
this confident to be honest i was
probably
um yeah real shy back in school um but
yeah it's like like if you know
something you're real confident you know
but like if you don't know what you're
like real shy like
like don't pick me so i think that's
probably one thing that like i've used
rugby as they're good examples
i can be so much confident with it just
because i know about it
and one game that stands out for me for
your from your otago times is obviously
the ramfully shield game where no this
is this is a story of a lifetime there
should be a movie made about this the
ruptured testicle he plays on and wins
the shield
oh one of the greats
yeah that was quite it was funny because
it was like quintuple he gave me like a
knee straight to the nut and like and
then like yeah knee straight
you know it popped and um
i uh managed to i was like nah
something's wrong here you know like
something's wrong
this pain's real bad so i tell the
doctor nah i can't play anymore you're
gonna suck me out so
suzumiya and uh mitch
mitch scott pulls a calf or something
like he pulls something real bad and
there's no one on the bench and he's
like five minutes to go and we're up and
they're like oh chuck you you have to go
back on so i'm like oh okay then i'm
limping on and i'm like low-key and pain
like
maybe like a seven out of ten pain eight
out of ten and i get there and like
which all we have to do is kick it and
they just go chuck come in and block
bridge i'm like i don't want a bridge
like collect the ball out so if you see
this video i'm like in there and i'm
bridging four bit lights they don't hit
me like
and uh like we were in and then like i'm
cheering along but after the game my mom
comes up to me and i was like mom my
back is so sore and my mom's like
rubbing my back like is this fine is
this fine like this is all right and
like as mom's doing they're like
nah i think she's so sore like and i was
like hunched over like just couldn't
stand up straight
you know i get to the uh showers and
i'm having a shower and then i like i
look down holy it's a bloody shot
football like you know it's like swollen
and i'm like it's really big itself but
this one's only it was like bigger than
big it was a weird wheel so i was like
still dirty like i just i legit just got
in the shower
soap like i was like soaked up a bit and
i was like gee i've got to get out of
here so like while i'm still so good
like run over to doc now because i'm
like nah like something's wrong so they
chucked me on the table and then they
like
see another oh threw up like straight to
the
emergency room like stolen like my kit
like i haven't even had a shower
properly and
have x-ray and
scan and stuff and then you know they
they put me for surgery and they put me
on a trip
and then
i have surgery the next morning but the
team
flies down to need it and that was like
our
i've heard about that parade that they
have at the at the import that they do
down here um so because that was our
first time i was like i gotta make this
flight and and uh the doctor's like oh
we'll have to have you overnight again
oh no no no no no no
i've got to get there i've got to be in
that flight
and he's like no no after surgery you've
got to stay another night and i was like
okay and then the nurse comes up to me
after the doctor's oh now you can like
discharge yourself so oh sweet sushi
i'll just do that so should i switch it
so i discharged myself straight after um
straight after surgery but like the
thing is it's like so weird they took
they put me in a jock truck strip order
was that you called him yeah and i don't
know what they were you know and um i
so what they did is like oh we'll just
chuck you straight into your clothes
straight away so
thank you very much so i woke up in my
tiger kit
like all like ready to go like polo and
all right well thanks so much and you
know i go to the flight and um all the
boys are like show our show or shows i
was like i can't show you but you know i
showed them and then like one of them i
pulled my like just pulled the back of
my pants down and he was like gee are
you wearing a g string i was like
and i was getting like real like he's
like why are you picking on me like i
just lost the nap
and like i didn't lose it now but like i
was just like and then like pizza i
pulled it down and then they were all
laughing at me and i'm like what am i
wearing like i can't be wearing this
but yeah anyway we managed to come down
to the meeting and
quit the flight oh it was great and then
they apparently like one of the flight
attendants must have heard that i
ruptured my um
my testicle and she gave me like some
almonds some chocolate almonds on the
flight gave me a weird announcement too
and i was like thank you
oh that's one of the great so did you
lose a nut or no you still got two
yeah i still got two i still got two
uh because it was so big
yeah do you know how it's so big like
it's hard to explain to someone like so
because it's so big it's so easy to like
sold up but if you have a small one it's
pretty hard to
yeah
is it so is it bigger now like does it
affect your rugby at all or does it help
your rugby momentum
um yeah more testosterone before the
game probably i'd say
just creeps creates a bit more
oh good times um and then obviously
moving to the highlanders i think i
think you were what
two or three years before you got there
islanders call up
um what was it like when you finally got
there
oh it's unreal that's a story by itself
as well so on my last year of the sevens
in like 2019 to vietnam
[Music]
would you be keen to go to the
highlanders this is like mid-season like
we're just about to go vancouver the
greatest place in the whole university
of sevens
and i was like you know double minded
like i want to go to vancouver but i
want to go to like two great like i want
to go super rugby and um
i tell the boys quickly like gee and i
think i'm off like i think i'm off to
the landers and then they're like
[ __ ] i was like yo like so anyway
like they have this massive argument
with the sevens and and the highlanders
that
they were like trying to give me a
contract to go straight away but like
the sevens went letting me go so then i
was like i'll burn bridges here like i
burnt bridges at the seventh because i i
said that i was just gonna leave
and then i was like oh my god in the
back of my head i'm not going to
vancouver like you know like oh my gosh
like vancouver's the best place and i've
like just
one place i want to go to and i've just
burnt myself here like and then when i
get named to go to vancouver and you
know i'm like i'm like you know trying
to suck the boys the coaches and the
stuff like thanks guys i appreciate it
like i'll never leave yous you know
i didn't want to leave he's anyway i
love this environment
funny enough was in vancouver and that's
where the great the great promos came
along that year um but yeah yeah yeah so
yeah it went also i was quite happy that
like the landers were keen on me like in
2019 when they had injuries so um lucky
enough that they just signed me straight
to 2020 so it was kind of cool that um
yeah i already had to deal with them
before the year even finished till the
7th so that was kind of um
yeah yeah it was just
yeah it's probably the one thing that
you want to dream about is just like
having a conscious super contract
you're not even like you're not fighting
for one you've already got one so
it's probably a cool thing and what was
the biggest difference going from um the
npc to super rugby or from sevens what
was the biggest difference for you
said again
what was the biggest difference going
into super rugby from mpc oh
uh just more money eh
like you just see like you know like
no no not more money in terms of me like
more money in the
system like
yeah
like oh yeah and that one and now i need
more money both ways
now definitely definitely um i don't
know they just yeah it's just it's great
like there's nothing that's like on a
budget all night like you know there is
a budget but like it's way more than
what a npc team would have and
um
just like hotels and stuff like
yeah just yeah that's probably the one
thing that i took out of is like
you you get quality stuff and like yeah
which is quite good like it's not
quantity it's quality that counts
that's it that's that's you know that's
a wee gym for the day
and it was a 2021 season where you
really sort of lit the compo light um
or
some some form you're in that yeah
scoring tries everywhere carving teams
up
um what was it like that year for you
and where did that form sort of come
from or was that boys just
did you always have it just waiting for
an opportunity
yeah i think i was just waiting for an
opportunity um
but also just just backing myself really
like i think uh
not too sure what came it was maybe it
was like the
i think we played
uh now maybe the ba uh the brumbies over
in canberra oh yeah and that's probably
like one of the games where i was like
oh i can like compete you know i can
compete in this competition so that's
probably one game that i took out like
like my size i ain't the biggest swinger
so like you know it's just how do i make
it work for myself and
um just the point of difference like
yeah what can i do that other wingers
can't do and things like that and just
working on it we can work out it's
probably the one thing that i took out
of that first year and just really
believing in myself
and did you ever get any feedback from
the all blacks i mean i know there's a
lot of speculation around you
potentially being in the squad that yeah
there's a bit of a bolter but did you
have any feedback around it
no no no not at all no
i'll probably go play for you to be
honest i'll probably just i think
they're they're lacking in the first
five so over there
well mate i was gonna i was gonna ask
you that like obviously you are eligible
for
new zealand and fiji is that genuinely
what you're thinking would you go to the
rugby world cup with fiji this year if
you
if you can
yeah
yeah if i if i can i think but i think
um all my contracts at the moment i
think i'm tired i'm locked in here so
um i'm not too sure if i could
somehow
not have that in my in my country i'm
pretty sure that
usually i'm locked in for the new
zealand side oh so you've got a new
zealand rugby union contractor on top of
your uh
no no no it's just like the
holland is one it's like has this like
claws in it that i can't
go play for like a national
no the national team like i have to be
new zealand eligible or something like
that so
that's probably the one thing that's
holding me back
true
so you would go you'd be off straight
away to fiji
oh think about it i'll think about it
interesting you'd be handy at that
um rugby world cup for fiji probably
around
full back asha because there's that many
wingers they've got going yeah
honestly like that's what they're
missing i reckon it's just a good first
drive and a good fallback like yeah
andy yeah
yeah
oh yeah
oh
wait but then obviously in your
highlanders time that um knee injury
sort of struck it quite a niggly time um
well you've spoken about the rehab
process but how did you deal with that
initially when when you first found out
you were had done your acl and you're
out for nine months or whatever it was
yeah
um
it was actually funny because like you
know when you're like young you think
you're bulletproof
that's the funny thing that's that's a
good putty putty
pony parkinson um quote i'm bulletproof
you know
give him a wee plug there um yeah so
like at the time like i did my knee and
the funny thing is you know like doctors
and physios
they know that you've done your acl but
they never tell you at the time
and all they do is like oh no we'll get
a scan on monday like you'll be fine
like you know but they know they
definitely know that you just did your
acl like there's no hiding it like it's
funny because your specialists don't
know how you can do their test and like
you can feel your aclu yeah no i'm like
i was like
when the when the special is doing it
like so my doctor my physio just lied to
me straight in the face you know like
like you know my acl was gone and they
just told me now we'll just wait for the
scab ggg no you know you don't need that
scan
so you know um i like i have the scan
and
i um
because yeah here and then i have the
scan like uh doc calls me is ah
unfortunately uh
it's not it's not good news there jonah
um
you've done your purpose in jcl so
you'll be out before we walk oh yeah
what like five months three months
is that nine nine months and all this
my heart just sucked out holy like nine
months what do i do in nine months like
i might as well just you might just say
12 months like
put me on christmas life you know rip me
up and leave me underneath the tree
carefully
you know so like i was like ah like and
then i thought about it in the
ah you can either take it to two ways
like you can even feel sorry for
yourself or just take this opportunity
to i think make it as a positive so i
think i took it as a positive way um
yeah didn't really see it as
is
me missing out
as like
i think that's what i kind of
took better is like when the boys were
training i was like
they're missing out on my fun
instead of me missing out on the team's
fun it was like i tried to flip it and
like so every day i'd take shannon's jet
ski out and i'd like just go in the
harbor like because i was there because
i was training for like two hours maybe
an hour and a half every morning
i'll just touch in and oh i'm taking the
jet ski out like so i'll just take the
jet ski and just turn around in the
harbor while the boys are training in
the stadium like they'll be turning
around sending everyone snaps that i'm
on the jet ski like have a weak chrono
in the back like just popping it open
and i don't drink the thing is i don't
drink but i just had like a crown in the
back just not like they can think oh
well this guy's actually living life
but um yeah and then i just pour it down
pour in a little bit and recycle the
bottle but um
yeah that's probably the one thing i
took out of there um
the bad news which i kind of made into a
good news right i like that mindset and
obviously that's why you've come back in
such red hot form but you did mention a
few fishing um a little bit about your
fishing and jet ski i know you've got
some good fishing and jet ski story
especially with shannon so
may
take it away
oh poor shannon so haha gotta get
comfortable here jim so um
so it was it was shannon's first day of
buying his jet i was like he just bought
his jet ski he bought her a wanaka
massive jet ski like it was a fishing
one and um
what do you call it so well like uh
he's like he's taken it out in wanaka
he's honed it around a bit and then he's
come down here in daniel and i'm like oh
you got to take me out shane you gotta
like legit take me out so it's his first
time having a jet ski so like you know
you've got to bear with us here so we go
to um we go to the harbour the docks
and
we're like pulling up and there's a lot
of there's like a couple families there
there's like a family that's waiting to
go out and there's a family waiting to
come in
and there's one one um ramp
a couple ramps but one was getting you
so then i said oh [ __ ] we'll just put it
down here so shannon like tells me i'll
do this do that like yep and i'm like
yeah tick tick tick yep that's it
and then i reverse i reverse the trailer
in and and put the jet ski in and this
family is like legit like right next to
us and they're like holy that's a nice
jet ski and i was like oh yeah it's not
mine it's um that's my friend here
yeah yeah it's the new new jet ski
just going go gotta go for hoon i mean
it's probably the worst day to ever go
beforehand on the jet skip that day by
the way
and um
said shin is oh yeah stop stop stop give
me up so he got out and then he was like
oh so he's on the jet ski
and i was like oh push push so i'm like
frosting this jet ski like trying to
launch it off the trailer
and he's oh no no no no no the chain so
we unhook the chain you'll get chambered
so yeah unhook the chain and it's like
yeah now do it now so it starts to jet
ski up and he's like reversing but this
family's like looking at us
these guys are all good like these guys
don't know what they're doing anyway i'm
like let's see
it's like diamond dumber you know and
i'm just thrusting like trying to push
this jitsuke off and i'm like see
shannon this ain't coming off
so anyway
we like shannon jumps off the disc and
we're both trying to push this jet ski
off and i'm like nah there's something
wrong here so you know shane's like
like that's like scratching his head
he's like oh i left the straps on she
sort of stopped on the back of the jet
ski i still stopped and i was like
so we're looking like rookies here on a
brand new jet ski we just have to like
the thing is we have to drive this [ __ ]
the truck back up
take those drops off to go reverse back
down oh my days and i'm like gee you're
making us look like amateurs and i'm
like while the families are looking at
us i'm like making us look like amateurs
and what like you like slept because he
you know we get off and like we're like
honestly it's like is that speaker
there's those like bluetooth speakers
and we're just honing it and you know
like
in a dock
um these those uh limit uh
those speed limits that you're like it's
like ten or
five knots
and um outside uh in the harbor it was
like it was choppy as like was bad like
the worst day you could ever take a jet
season real bad and i was like nice
shannon like we gotta go back in
and we didn't read the sign and the sign
said 10 knots or five knots so anyway
we're in this dock and we're just
blasting these island jams like holy
heckle it was loud just turning it the
thing is we're trying to pull who can
who could pull the fastest and like a in
a 20 20 meter oh no maybe like a 50
meter
um
length and like oh you're going 50 knots
people like first pumping each other and
laughing and then we get these two old
men that come over to the dock and
they're like oh
and they're like calling us open and i
was like oh [ __ ] what's wrong here yeah
shut up put the volume
don't you read the signs it can't go um
over five knots and i was like
i was like so stunned oh my
oh it says jitsuki so i just put shading
straight into it like oh he was driving
into this jet ski and shannon's fully
like oh sorry it's my first time having
this and i'm just like longing at the
back like don't even suck your balls
like that so you know i was just
laughing and then like we second and we
just like jump back on the trailer and
like just head off home we're like both
giggling on the way home but
like we're idiots like we can't be doing
that we need and then we're like now we
we finally um
read the rules of like docs and stuff
and
like rules around the water and stuff
like that so now we know so
it was a good experience like that's
what i said to shannon hey we don't
chase fish or chase experience
and the fish just come
the first just come a hundred percent
oh that is good stuff mate that is a
good yarn i knew you and you had a good
fishing on there that was a good one so
we will go to the questions because i
might we've still got plenty more not
these ones aren't from oh no no no jim
i've got another story for you oh
another fishing yard go on
this is this is a good one this is
probably the best one
there's a slot you know me and me and
shannon are probably like the worst
fisherman in in
the whole universe of fisherman and um
so we wake up and we wake up and like do
now fishing fishermen so this is how i
think fishermen do they probably wake up
and they go see the ocean you know
what's a bit choppy today maybe like
maybe not maybe like you know check
maybe the forecast and stuff but me and
shannon we did the opposite we wake up
we look at the sun oh it's a nice day
let's go fishing you know yeah so anyway
this one day we're like let's go fishing
this is a beautiful day
but beautiful day up in the sky but not
on the water so it's the worst day you
could ever go fishing
and mention and have this we have this
anthem let's try i'll try to show you
this um
trying to figure out this anthem so we
have this fishing anthem that we always
play just before we go fishing and we
reckon it gives us good luck and um
it is called uh
i'm gonna miss her
it's just you know just the way track
that we're playing and you know we're
just chanting away like shannon's
outside and i'm just driving next to him
on the beach and we're like just about
to reverse it
this day is like the worst day like
these tides were probably like
the sets were probably like four sets
and they're really close together but i
was like jeez we can't back out now had
our bait really cut up hawks thought
hooks lines like everything was set
you know put the jet ski in
and um check it on and the thing is like
me shannon i could read we can read each
other's um
what like what the motions are you know
so yeah i'm like oh shannon do you wanna
do you wanna draw like shannon you can
drive like so i'm trying to give it to
him to drive and shannon's like oh no
you drove so i'm like oh this guy's not
confident so okay i'll drive it
i get on the jet ski and i'm like oh
that's us let's go so we're like driving
around driving around and i'm just
trying to time this tire day like
perfectly
and anyway the thing about shannon is he
like you can hear like his voice oh
you'd know shannon like his voice is
like real defined like
stop
like you know stop
that's how you sound wow anyway i'm like
i'm going through i'm going through the
waters like i'm just
pounding these waves like
wave off the way i'm just going then
shannon's at the back of me and he's one
of those backseat commentators like
backseat drivers
no truck not that one like and i'm like
they're like let me drive like i'm
telling them in this wow this is like a
windy choppy day and anyway i get
through one get through the other indian
i just see this wave start to building
and i'm like i can hone this if i time
this well we're going straight across
right
but like shannon like gives me doubt
like at the wrong time and it's like
curves the wave just curves and he's
like [ __ ] pull out
and i'm like i was too late like legit
jim it's too late this waves up and i'm
like right underneath it so i just hold
it like the only thing i can do is just
hone it so i'm honing in oh we're going
straight to the moon man let's
feel like straight up all i see is the
sky and i'm like no like what am i doing
anyway the thing is shannon jumps off
the jet ski so he just like jumps off
the jet ski and he just goes into the
water and i'm like and it makes the jet
ski like like a tip just because he's
kicked off oh yeah and i'm just i don't
know at this point i don't know i'm just
like please like i gotta take this chips
key down to the water you know so i'm
like up in the air
calm down and once it like once the
water once the jessica hits the water i
pop off
funny thing is i don't put the jet ski
key on my um
on my jacket so the jet ski was like
running and i'm underwater right i'm
just underwater like and i'm just like
my heart's like racing i'm like i've got
to find this jitsu just because these
tides are coming and once like one tide
gets this jitsuke me and shannon if
we're just
so i'm like oh monster is boom i've got
to get out of this water and i'm going
to find the jet ski as soon as possible
so i like go down and i just jump up
like i just touch the ground and i just
jump up
and i look around i find the jet ski
jump on the jet ski and i'm like honing
like i'm just like where's shannon like
i just can't see [ __ ] he's like tumbling
underneath the wall yeah just tumbling
all i can see is there's like life
jacket just tumbling and i'm like oh
this is by rescue type stuff you know
and i'm like you know get into lifeguard
mode and i'm like looking around like
and there's this massive like set just
coming right behind me so i'm like yeah
i gotta go so i hone out who now all the
way back to the beach and um
shannon like pops up his head and he
goes
sure
come back
turn around like there must be a reason
why
he's left like he wouldn't be next to
you know
this guy doesn't think you know at the
point
think it must be like a wave coming so
anyway he's like growling me to come
back to him and he turns around and this
wave just demolishes him just starts and
he's just in this like washing machine
just wait he like gets up all i see is
i'm on the beach just watching him
because i'm like stuck i can't go get
him and then in my head i was like you
know he's always like you know if one
person it's better if one person dies
than two so one can tell the story
[Laughter]
well that's how the mindset you know the
mindset in my head was like hey i could
tell this story but if both of us die no
one can tell the story so you know so
i'm like no i'll just watch him so i'm
on the beach and i'm just like watching
him like please get out like you know
like please somehow just get out of here
and i'm just on the street i'm on the
jet ski and the shallows like
what do i do like where do i go and
they're like shin is just getting
tumbled off the tumble and um anyway he
like comes up like after like five
minutes they're getting like you know
swashing he stands up
stands up and he's just laughing like he
has a smaller space and i'm just on this
i just doc i just launched the um the
jet ski back on the beach and i'm just
like on the on the beach just laughing
like what the hell that just went
through like what do we just go through
and you're like me and him just start
giggling but the funny thing is we went
to hushing hunting and fishing that
morning
and we bought like these new jerseys
like these new pants the thing is and
we're telling each other like i don't
think these pants were like tested to go
underwater like we just tested them and
men who were just cracking up and all
just soaked on the beach just laughing
and
oh one of the greatest stories because
then when we told like our management
and they were like you guys are idiots
and no no no that's the thing though
which is experience not fish
that's one of it that's one of our many
mottos
oh mate that is great that is a funny
yeah but also quite scary yeah right
that sounds like yeah pretty scary when
you see shannon getting almost drowning
there but
like you said
oh mate that that yeah and one of the
greats absolutely worth it i think that
was actually the first question too
because it was a
question about um a fishing trip with
shannon so it might have been that one
so
um good good to get that one out the way
okay next one ask him how long it took
him to do brake pads on his car
the mechanic chock mechanic must have
been quick
now wasn't unfortunately just because i
had like you know me i just had to make
some tools up on the spot because i
didn't have my two i wasn't in the the
garage it was like makeshift stuff and i
made it work you know medium i make
things work and as you know um took me
half a day to take to change one brake
pad on one side and then i went down to
my mechanic mate and he changed it in
five minutes and i was [ __ ]
because
i was so proud of myself that it took me
half a day to do it in my like in my
driveway yeah and then for him to do it
in five minutes it just broke me but hey
you live and you learn hey you know
learn some tricks
tricks in the trade of
of a job
chock mechanic charging overtime half a
day on a oh hundred percent
100
okay next one ask him about his hunting
adventure with squid
well this is great yeah no means could
go way back me is good
well like this i mean it's good the
funny thing is people don't understand
like me and squid are like legit like
everyone thinks i'm a towny oh i'm i'm a
farmer i'm a southern man from fruit you
know i'm a horseback type person
oh wait wait jim i gotta show you this i
might send you one hold on okay
i want to send you this i'm actually
supposed to give you this um
oh the southern man look at that
is that you on there
yeah oh of course mate you're right i'll
send the team you just send me your
email your um your little box
get it in the studio that would look
good in here
yeah i know right all right that's a
great flick i might say it's a great
poster holy
yeah now i mean it's good yeah we always
go hunting but the thing is squid's
pretty smart i'll give squid there you
know he's he's he's he's good he's good
um anyways so he caught this pig he must
have caught this big quarter uh like
maybe like five months ago and it was a
massive pig and i said oh i'm just gonna
go check this this pig out if you want
to come
and i was like oh okay yeah i'll come so
anyway
i'm a you know big good guy i am alright
i'll come the man doesn't tell me it's
like three hours away
and i'm like sitting in the in the
passenger seat like
like are we doing like are we why is it
like taking so long like you know okay
it's good where are we going but anyway
he's like yeah anyway
and then anyway we find this pig and
it's in this like valley like this this
galley so and i'm like oh my gosh like
who's carrying this like and i think
squid's knee was playing up their day
too and i've just i just started running
so i was like i ain't carrying it so
like
who's gonna carry it out of us
you know it was just massive pickles
probably like
it was like 207 pounds or something like
that so like and it was yeah so squid's
like max so he was like oh but i got it
i gotta get this out and i was like oh
yeah okay good luck
oh yeah good luck and then like he's oh
see like i help him put on his back and
you know squid's massive but like this
this hog was just huge
and then he's like nah like and his
knees are shaking like and i was like oh
no this ain't good like i'm just like
that enough we just have to like um
to put on like a poem we're just like
inching it up this hill yeah and it took
us like two hours or three hours to get
it up
but like it was so the hill was that
quick legit that hill was like 40
minutes like it was a 40 minute hike but
it was like a two and a half hour like
all that pig it was like that deadly and
and then half yeah it's just like a big
day three hours in the car two hours
carrying the pig
and the thing is like we woke up at 5 00
a.m you know like
but yeah great y'all just good because
yeah
one of the greats right no wonder well
one of the greats oh
100 he's one of the greats and um the
funny thing is he's like it's so good
going hunting with him because he's got
a side by side so you just like just
chill on the
chill and just let the dogs run out but
we took this is a quick quick gun for
you we took shannon out and shannon
knows that squid has like his gun with
him
and um we took shannon out maybe like a
couple months ago before he went
and um
uh what did he call it he i don't know
shannon had a gun
but this is the funny honors um he
thought there's squid's gun so he bought
this gun and um i got to i got to scorch
truck before shin shannon was dark it
was like five o'clock in the morning and
i got into the truck and i just in this
in the light i could see shannon holding
a gun case
and he is so proud of himself john like
smile from like cheek the chicken he's
just like
good you're going to be proud of me
holding my gun you know like just can't
wait for school to be like oh [ __ ] you
put your gun
so anyway we get we get to the field and
shannon pulls out his gun that's a bb
gun oh my oh my days i'm like gee the
pigs are gonna laugh at us like don't be
carrying that around like oh i'm done
the funny thing is i was like i was
making it worse i was making the
situation worse and scared was on
shannon so that's all good like you know
but i was just ripping into shannon like
see those bullets are not hurting anyone
and then um
[ __ ] thing is i was like oh squid
chuckles your bullets and it's good here
there's like a box of bullets and like
he was like and i like grabbed him on my
hand i was oh nice and i was like oh
[ __ ] grab
show us your bullets in here like this
little tissue like this little ass test
tube and he was like palming it in his
hand and i was like oh my all i did was
just brought it off his head like that's
why we don't shoot your gun
we just had this like we just all loaded
and
you know just ended up shooting
right you and shin fozel should start a
um hunting and fishing um program if
you're one of the greats that's two
people
yeah people reckon we should but
yeah
definitely if i have another sabbatical
i'll get into it
hopefully not fingers crossed no more
sabbaticals but no end of end of career
okay next one this is the question from
our major sponsor swish if you could get
a video shout out from any celebrity who
would it be and why
probably uh
would either be neymar
oh i have to choose a few you'll be like
neymar
um
you know name i'll just have to be
neymar actually but like what kind of
good yeah what kind of good friends
anyways
you got you look quite like him i do you
get that off then
yeah well i copied some of those texts
to be honest like i need to put
something here and then i'll be neymar
you know but
like yeah we're already friends anyway
like so i don't need a shout out from
him but like if he wanted me to shout
him out i mean
if swiss can do that i could i'll
happily help out but
hey all right lads couple of lads get
him on the podcast too neymar yeah ask
him ask him to come on he'd be a good
one yeah
yeah
well we're supposed to meet up for lunch
sometime i think he's flying his jet
over here because
you know yeah
going on the um jetski take him out yeah
okay next one uh what was your
inspiration for the slingshot try
celebration
oh i think about myself is the robin
hood of the otago community
i i i steal from the i steal from the
rich and give to the poor
what are you laughing youtube that's a
great great one
that's that's why you know that's why
the arrows come out because robin hood
you know
good all right that is good stuff okay
next one uh what's the ambush committee
crew
ambush committee career it's just it's a
well-oiled
crew that um meets up every wednesday or
every wednesday or tuesday and we go to
mcdonald's but the thing is it's not
about the meal it's about connection
and the good thing about mcdonald's is
there's kids there we could connect with
the kids as well as eat our fatty meals
a little bit dodgy so i think
yeah a little bit dodgy during during a
week of prep for super rugby game but i
think about it as a promo you know a
promo that you're not going to get paid
for but
it's not what people see you know like i
hope people don't tell
the coaches and stuff that oh we seem
like german ricky and his crew like
eating mecca's on wednesday but
yeah that's a great christmas robin hood
doing his thing
oh exactly you know stealing from the
rich giving to the pool
i'd almost get that territory here today
you've got a few good mottos you could
have tattooed on your neck a few have
come out really
i like them okay next one
this is a this is probably a little bit
to do with your poster that you just
showed us but um why does he call
himself a southern man but scared of a
space
nah sir that that was that was back in
the day like maybe like a year ago that
our skill of space but now i'm just oh
you'd have to like you'd have to shoot
my hand off to not get one you know like
it's that it's that dangerous and it's
no ultra too it's the full cream one oh
that's what i mean you know i've
actually i actually enjoyed him now
which is quite um interesting because
yeah i was more of a um
i was more of like a uh
bloody i wouldn't say cocktail but like
you know a mixed type person you know
mix like malibu pineapple type person we
sweetness yeah
michael collins will be proud that was
sent in from him
oh yeah yeah hey he would be proud the
thing is he didn't drink no speeds i
could tell you that
he weren't drinking those foods he was
drinking some pink gin i could tell you
that i got some photos
oh good stuff okay last question
ask this one every episode best piece of
advice you have for a waterled listener
and
going from this episode there's been so
much already i feel like
i'm i'm being a bit greedy asking for
one more
oh now what would you i forced to say um
what would you want would you want a
serious one would you want a joking one
oh mate
um
for me it would be probably if i was to
thought to reword that um
be
i think make the most out of life
because there are some people that
probably
are struggling and they probably um
would want but you know like you can't
can't always be sad i feel like you know
you've got to make the most of every day
because i think about it if i was to
flip it around like imagine if like um a
young person passed away you know like
people like i had so much to live you
know like his whole life was in front of
him
so i flipped it around like i should
make the most out of my days my weeks
you know so
should we really go to bed and be stoked
of what i've accomplished in the day so
i think that's probably one thing i've
taken out of it is
really make the most out of every day
because you don't know what's going to
happen tomorrow um and yeah especially
especially being injured is like the
flip side is being injured you like like
i said like you can either
feel sorry for yourself or just take it
as a positive and and work on yourself
and work on something that you haven't
worked on before especially because you
have a lot of time i had a lot of time
i love that that is that is such a cool
mindset
very good chasing experience is not fish
i i guess you sum it up exactly hey
to be a lecturer at the uni
psychology school was that too much am i
asking for too much i genuinely think
you'd be really good at it listening to
this mate
don't think i've learned as much from a
podcast as i have from this one not just
knowledge
the confidence you've got everything so
it's been awesome to have you on the
podcast
really appreciate you coming on
excited to see what's next for you
actually um obviously after your
eight-week sparkle
heading into the back end of this year's
bunnings npc then super rugby potential
world cups new zealand fiji
right we've got a lot to watch um you've
got an exciting exciting few years
coming up for you so i'm looking forward
to following that but appreciate you
coming on the podcast mate and sharing
some of your classic yeah
thank you i appreciate having me on
all right you're a led
[Music]
what
[Music]